bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo su rocket
league con ciccio è in mezzo a noi
la persona swag che c'è scritto alpha è
uno dei campioni italiani di rocket
licenza è uno dei giocatori italiani più
forti che ci sono solo che tutti si
chiama già ma anche io sono due era io
sto parlando di te ciccio non però mica
nell'altro si come voi sapete che io me
la cavo rocket league anche ciccio è
molto bravo nei video che facciamo
vinciamo spesso ecco adesso non faceva
troppo ridere non l'hai preso sul serio
ecco adesso faremo due contro uno cioè
io e ciccio contro questa sola persona e
voi direte beh due contro uno vi farete
un culo così no ci aprirà l'anno a
entrambi sono perché questa è veramente
uno dei giocatori più forti d'italia di
rocket league che si è prestato a fare
questa partita con noi quindi le pera la
partita privata facciamo d'europa ora se
anch'io
dicevo quando faceva le viti di
matematica da ma uguale sta tranquillo
sta tranquillo ci sono qua io sono il
compagno e suggerisce da quello famiglia
a posto sei pronto ciccio io sono
arrabbiato il libro un libro vieni blu
ce la facciamo
6 il colore della stanza se già campione
eccelso stagione 7
già il titolo giallo mi fa cagare in
mano sei pronto per chi vale ciccio
approccio problema ho già vinto il primo
contrasto siamo ricorsi dal caldo nei
negozi laparo io spingo lo spingo come
lo parata bene ci credo
vedi la previa corrivo va bene
all'inizio e per temprarsi va bene
ciccio ma da mikado ci ho creduto
fortissimo ha gi joe io guarda che bravo
ora che bravo player bravissimo buona
pratica non dovesse fossi stato un
campione come lui avremmo vinto 4 a 0
adesso immagino
oggi giulio allora tra tutti i ruoli il
portiere quello che mi si addice di meno
dai cc che cosa ho fatto uscire che
cattiveria e stana tattica che uso io la
schiaccia contro il muro della barca
vacca poiché faro ha preso il culo che
lei ci diceva allora piano piano piano
ti qua dobbiamo capire scherzavo veloce
veloce però quello fatto da come lo
[ __ ] è visto mamma mia si è cagato
addosso l'ho visto che tremava perché
come abbiamo scelta prender gol noi si
chiama star
io sono il gran bazar non puoi perdere
cioè vincere era convinto neanche lui di
quello che ha detto vai vai vai vai o
chiocchio la parola però io come la farò
bene
mamma mia è già stato recarsi a casa vai
che hai giocato a minchia riguarda i
tornei mondiali
ascoltami secondo me avviare l'azione
adattivi a questa cosa proprio non lo
rendere ecco visto è presa la prende
sempre sta cagando sotto jam e alla
frutta si no
ma non ne sbaglia una sarai in consiglio
come 6 a 0 ma deve essere più trono
regale colpisci la forte forte ancora
qualificarlo come fregare bravissimo
madonna nessun problema nessun problema
nessun problema ed è difficile basta
troppo forti troppo forti ecco visto da
altri sei colle altri segue basta fare
un gol ogni 10 secondi c'è già ma la
stefi il tuo ruolo
nata come un idiota allora però l'ho
tolta
non ho tolta io credo che aiuterà i loro
livelli è uno stress con un divertimento
sì sì sì ma non mi sembra contestato in
questo momento che tiro ha fatto oggi
prendiamo feticcio ma dai
guardavano fatto di howard gara che
provata incredibile aspetta bravissimo
cina e gran bravo e vabbè strano ma non
riesco a togliermi era capito neanche se
si doveva non riesco a toglie la
controlla madonna dall'altra porta ci
sono nella nostra porta di gesù
l'altra porta ma l'ultima volta che ho
visto un horror del genere era venerdì
non uno a 13 beh come prima partita e
bilanciata equilibrata si ha voglia di
rivincita perché secondo me ce la
facciamo carica ok bravo ok bravo una
sega li facciamo lo stesso
troppo ambiente non fa niente va bene
allora si parte sempre dando un punto di
vantaggio agli avversari perché sono in
minoranza ma il suo carica vadano a
caricando aver carico io ora come volo
come lui grava che bravo hai visto come
volato bene vai vai col piscina bravo
tranquillo tranquillo attacco punto io
vado in difesa nonostante chi sa che
vedono però è completamente coperta
bravi tensione 11 varato una norma c'era
una cava l'ho fatto è che viaggia nel
tempo come tutti lo ha fatto che tira il
premio del 20
guarda questa già basa bones the king of
the game
sicuramente non io credo che la partita
è nostra e alla frutta ora come si sta
cagando sotto lo vedi vado io vado
scherzavo
no chiocchio prendi la prendi a ciccio
spend bravo lolli però che ti fotte
scusa e retromarce me ne sono accorto cc
è no vai di style a norma perché vide
demolire bravo braida solo dei voliamo
l'ho pure tanto perdiamo uguale ma siamo
una 3 ancora recuperabile a brown ciccio
riccio che sogno ma niente ci ho creduto
non lascia quando si crea bruno
attenzione ma perché ho 25 punti su 250
ma dei punti di consolazione in realtà
non hai fatto niente di 0 0 a 60
partizan tiri però il ring più alto
niente con la [ __ ] ad ora ci credo ci
credo ci sto credendosi
tattica porta difesa a parte difesa
funziona o no sono scemo visto per
tranquillo se l'ogiva di un altro
partire bella bella bella bella bella
mamma mia ciccio 65 punti stai
migliorando ma dovevo andare sulla porta
un errore mio
gesù non toccarla scusa fa niente per
niente buona formula bravo così abbiamo
fatto una giocata talmente brutta che
non se l'aspettava neanche no sto
facendo ma dai parà la palla facile
parata
questo ti è successo a oggetti oppure
meno male che fini meglio tipo 11 kijiji
ancora uno ancora una l'ultima amico mio
dobbiamo portare in alto il nostro nome
sento come credi in conto presa vice
esattamente chi è che il day 2
io faccio sempre schifo tu sei tu sei
donna lo sono tolto occhio che la doc
movie demolisce così non è tutte cose
brutte
a padova ho scartato ronaldo uno che
gigi bravissimo
non ci credo cosa ci succede persa
drasticamente quasi pareggiata e adesso
siamo incendio alla sul siena sta
succedendo non tocca tocca tocca in
qualche modo ormai non così ma va bene
per ea due ok cazzo dovrebbe in qualche
modo tipo live europa prova perché ho
detto quella frase li ha quasi fare già
ciccio mag anima e da solo no non ci
credo
ciccio 4 gol in un minuto e 43
io ci credo non so perchè ci credo bravo
bravo cosa è successo e se è diventato
un fenomeno golfi na questa è la mia
attirati devi segnare a porta vuota
tre gol in cinque secondi ce la facciamo
ci manca solo che segna la fine no mi
incazzo perfetta allora l'abbiamo
salvato la partita adesso ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto
io ringrazio ciccio per la
partecipazione costruito da toscana in
descrizione anche quelli già ma sa che
non credo abbia un canale però va beh
spero che mi sia piaciuto piaciuto non
mi piace come si sa sono state esistente
decidiamo
[Musica]